- [Voiceover] Welcome back, man.
Man, it feels so good
to be back in the U.S.A.
Oh, wow, you know, just
two and a half months
of backpacking all around the world.
- That sounds amazing.
- Yeah, you know, it was just like,
culture shock, culture
shock, you know, just like,
- Wow.
- Learning about all these
different cultures and countries.
I'm just a changed man.
- Crazy. Well, hey, you
must be hungry, let's eat.
- Oh, starving.
It's crazy that we're about to have dinner
because I'm so use to
Nicaragua time that like,
it's normally breakfast.
- Oh, Nicaragua, you were down there?
- Yeah, Nicaragua, it was just beautiful.
I highly recommend it.
- Okay, cool, yeah.
- Oh, look at this,
they have the linguini with the meatballs.
I wonder how that's gonna hold up
to the one in Italy, you know?
- Is that how they said
linguini with meatballs?
- Oh, yeah, you know,
after spending three
and half days in Italy
you just start picking up Italian.
It's linguini with the meatballs.
- Yeah, I didn't, cause
that actually sounds
like a little offensive.
- I don't think it's offensive.
I think I'm doing their culture a service
by pronouncing their food
the way it's supposed to be pronounced.
Oh, this place has everything.
They even have kung pao chicken.
- That's actually
pronounced kung pao chicken.
I'm Chinese, so.
- Oh, have you been to China too?
- I mean, I haven't, but.
- Oh.
But you know what, I've had
all this stuff, you know.
I might just get some
greasy American food.
- Yeah, why don't we
just go with American.
- Oh, look, right here, grilled cheese.
That looks delectable.
- Zac, that's not how
we say grilled cheese.
- What am I gonna wash it down with?
Maybe a Sam Adams beer?
Maybe some water?
I'm gonna go for the pop.
- Really? You were over
in the Midwest too?
- Yeah, I had a layover in
Minnesota. A couple hours there.
- Minnesota, you mean?
- Minnesota.
Minnesota.
- Zac, I think you're
being kind of an asshole.
- Asshole.
- What even has that accent?
- Do you know you have an accent?
You have a California accent,
it comes out sometimes.
- You know what, Zac, I'm
done with this conversation.
I'm just gonna order.
Excuse me, yeah, we'll take
two kale salads, please.
Thank you very much.
(upbeat music)